alright guys I'm super excited I've got
Ken here we've got a lot to get through
but our goal today is we want to create
the single source of truth for all
things tokenization so whenever somebody
asks you what is tokenization why is it
important you can send them this one
podcast episode so tall task no pressure
Ken thank you so much Anthony of having
me
absolutely alright so real quick just
some people have perspective how did you
get into crypto what's your background
let's go through all that and we can
jump into tokenization stuff definitely
started out as a securities lawyer
worked in finance went back to academia
and intro and angeles is their general
counsel back in 2014 and then so i spun
out an affiliate identity called
republic to allow retail investors to
invest in stock common stock preferred
stock early-stage companies and then
from then on in 2017 helped coinless set
up help angel instead of coin list and
in the course of that seeing very well
that these tokens a lot of them are
gonna be deemed to be securities meaning
you gotta fire a compliant way for
everyday people to participate in own
tokens and that's why we launched
republic crypto got it and so let's talk
about the securities law stuff first
right so what were you doing there kind
of what was the things that interested
you on the security side kind of pre
crypt that Rick is now a lot of us of
super app Apple a couple but what were
you doing do wait at a view fin fin tech
it's basically half legal and half
business and then if you deal with
Silicon Valley in a component of
engineering when you deal with
investment there's an eighty years you
know of securities law to deal with
crypto navigates at the forefront at the
very edges of financial technology yeah
which means the legal component is
probably gonna be 70% or so and so it's
about navigating the murky landscape
going far enough to be ahead of the game
but not overstepping so that you end up
in federal prison but it's a delicate
dance so I think law is always going to
be a keeper
in tech but in crypto is gonna be you
know it has already been a major major
component absolutely nobody sense it and
so you go from securities law into the
like finance side right so maybe talk a
little bit about kind of what type of
financial organizations they're you mean
for you yep yes so when I left Google
and Proctor I tried a massive asset
management firm straight up front of
funds our counterparties was like Lehman
and bear stew and whatnot
and it was structuring fun products you
know all right all right Peter exactly
LP GP dish al you know checks into
billions into you know traditional
assets oh it got boring very quick right
it wasn't a whole lot of creativity so I
went back into academia and then Angeles
itself is a fund manager yeah the
syndication model and so we apply the
same thing we nudge the boundary a
little bit there on Broker Dealer
investment advisory law yeah and then we
left when the law changed to allow
retail investor to to invest in early
stage companies very cool and so when
you go to spin out reply we'll get to
that in a second right but let's talk
about AngelList
kind of pre you spinning Republic out
right so I think a lot of people don't
really know what AngelList is what the
benefits are but it's changed the way
that people look at financing private
companies right so maybe talk about kind
of what Angelus does and why it's
important soon avoid Navy started
Angelus back in 2011 mainly to provide
more information to entrepreneurs
venture financing which is you know this
black box you either lucky enough to get
to someone and get rejected without
knowing why doesn't was I mean very
little information at a time so started
out just as a literally a block
preventer Act and then over time I think
they saw an opportunity that once you
build an ecosystem of entrepreneurs and
investor then you can facilitate
investment the moment that you do that
the moment that you monetize on
investment activities then regulations
kick in and so they hire me as their
first general counsel when they first
launched The Syndicate product matching
investors to
to underlying startups absolutely and so
what's been the impact of AngelList
right because it really did open up
information access etc but how do you
look at that impact in non crypto or non
tokenized world but in still private
startups I would say before angel is you
gotta be very lucky to know one of three
dozen extremely well-connected
individual in Silicon Valley in order to
get financing so even if you're a very
high net worth person here in wash treat
or in Alaska you didn't have access to
deals and you didn't really care or know
how to vet early-stage startups so by
establishing a platform that a lot more
high net worth individuals now can
finance projects it increased the pool
of capital and it necessarily led to a
much wider field of entrepreneurs who
got funded since you know 2013/14
absolutely alright so you end up seeing
the change in the law that allows retail
investors to participate in in this and
really unaccredited investors right is
what we're talking about and you go to
spend republic out let's start with just
what is tokenization right so in your
mind that term gets thrown around all
over the place what does it mean to you
yep us for me it's basically employing
this new technology blockchain
technology that would bring a level of
fractionalization unprecedented because
it's so cheap the simplicity of
fractional izing something and the
automated impact of basically removed
the administrative costs out of it so I
would say liquidity and
fractionalization a two elements that
you add on to traditional financing and
those two key elements alone in my
opinion would generate I don't even know
how many hundreds of billions if not
trillions of value once you
disintermediate the measurements that
are permeating throughout the banking
system absolutely and so as you're doing
this
what type of regulatory environment is
there right so the technology is one
piece and when we can talk about that in
a second but the regulations make this
possible
yeah right and so let's go through kind
of each one of the regulations that
exist and then the exemptions themselves
right so if you don't use an exemption
what are your options as an entrepreneur
to to fundraise you know if you allow me
Anthony to just backtrack a one little
bit because the reason why Congress
passed this law to allow everyone to
invest there's a matter of you a
millionaire or not they didn't consider
crypto of course at a time but the
purpose behind that was actually
realized by the wave of ICO unbeknownst
to Congress so the reason why they open
up they changed the law to allow
everyone to invest was that the number
or the type of entrepreneurs they got
funded by venture capitalists fit a very
particular mode they gotta be massive
massive companies with massive potential
mostly people young male was from
Stanford Harvard and alike and
traditional venture capital mold that we
think of correct so basically it's a
very narrow lens and the other side of
the coin was that pretty much everyone
else 99.9 percent of the population
didn't get to participate in what has
been the biggest wealth generation event
until crypto so we lobby Congress and
then they changed the law to allow for
minimal small participation so that even
a teacher in Alaska can invest 50
dollars in the next Oberer and that $50
if Oba does really well can be more than
a million dollars worth in in value and
this regulation was called what the JOBS
Act the job three EPs or regulation
crowdfunding so I co of course at the
time and they were already ICO is being
done in 2015/16 in Asia
you have people anywhere everywhere
funding financing businesses project in
a way that was much further than what
the law even contemplated I hope it
could be so now it's just basically in
the US
is using an existing legal framework to
try to make what has already been a an
industry practice more compliant
impossible so really what people are
doing is they're taking a law that
exists on the books and they're
interpreting it in a new way based on
technology that was not available when
they largely passed or another way to
look at it is that now does the
framework there's a legal framework that
does allow for everyone to participate
does allow for open participation but
you have to operate within this legal
framework because otherwise the legal
risk not just from the SEC you know
cramming down is from potential investor
lawsuits it's just too high so the
current legal framework does actually
work it does come with a cost but it
does work no it makes sense let's start
a business a hypothetical business right
right so you and I want to start a
construction company kind of just a
traditional mainstream company that does
not have the multi-billion dollar
potential right so we're talking about a
traditional business and to get started
we need to go buy some equipment right
we need to hire some people kind of get
get operations off the ground and so
when you raise some capital yep what are
our options today so first you gotta
form a company okay either a limited
liability company or a true corporation
it's essentially just a legal entity and
pretty cheap pretty fast pretty cheap
pretty fast an LLC can be for him in
like less than 40 hours couple hundred
bucks
same thing for a corporation what you do
with that entity
how you gonna fundraise how you how you
going to capitalize it now that's a
range of option okay you can go to a
bank and say I have great credit you
know score please lend me a million
dollars that's probably gonna be a hard
sale unless you already have a lot of
assets B and it's a hard sell because it
they don't have a lot of collateral at
the businesses new history that they
would have to reach back to your person
asset to do it so for you know someone
who's under 30 for most people that's
not a reality yep the second one is to
convince friends family that hey I'm
building this business it's gonna be
really profitable why don't you lend me
Simoni and now pays you back mm-hmm
another way lending money and paying you
back itches fixed-income
right so over a period of time you get
back 10% 12% interest every single year
not super interesting or you can take in
it and it's hard to do because most
friends and family aren't used to
lending to businesses correct and they
may not have the capital to lend for
example if you lend someone $10,000 that
means 10% out of that every single year
you get gonna get $1,000 back convincing
people to lend you $10,000 so that every
single year to get a bit of return
that's that's a hard sale absolutely or
you can go to 20 friends and say hey
guys this is gonna be a big business
think I'm gonna sell like one day for a
lot of money why don't you each buy in
500 bucks so all together I get $10,000
I'm not gonna pay you back anything
until the company makes it big and then
your five hundred bucks is now gonna be
fifty thousand that's the equity sales
for people to to participate got it
VC essentially fits into the ladder you
know the ladder framework and so if I
don't get a bank or my friends to lend
me capital right non non-dilutive
capital then I've got to go and raise
equity capital right to fund the company
the options there would be I can go to
professional investors right venture
capital funds etc I can go to friends
and family they can buy some of that you
described but then there is this new
regulation right that has come out where
these exemptions under the JOBS Act
allow me to raise equity capital if I
sell a piece of my business to people I
might not know right so not friends and
family and they're not professional
investors what's my range of options
there on the regulation side since the
Great Depression until about two and a
half years ago the if you are raising
from people who you don't know and don't
know well you can only raise from
so-called accredited investors that mean
institutions that means loosely defined
people who are millionaires okay so so
pre JOBS Act
you can only raise money from accredited
investors and
this is something that a veil this is
something that is across the United
States across the world what does
everyone use his accreditation
talk me through kind of how this applies
McClure is much of the develop were
there's a limit or there's a minimum
requirement on anyone will be seeking to
invest in an early stage company these
legal frameworks really to protect
investors you don't want you know
grandma's and teachers go in quo loosely
defined by the law unsophisticated
financially and sophisticated to get
duped into investment opportunities the
law assume that if you're rich enough
that you know enough in order to protect
yourself
so wealth is used as a proxy for
sophistication or intelligence
unfortunately in the u.s. that's the
case okay and obviously in practice
that's not the case of course I've said
it before there's a lot of dumb rich
people right in fact the United States
the only country among the developed
work that doesn't have a sophistication
standard based on how much you know
rather than how much your net worth is
oh so interesting so other countries
have both a wealth criteria and a
sophistication criteria correct so in
the UK or Canada if you have spent a
year working for a financial institution
in an investment capacity then you
deemed to be an accredited investor
their definition of a crap got it and so
really it's an either/or right you can
have a million dollars or meet some
wealthy criteria or you could have
worked for a year at a goldman sachs
wherever correct and just the standard
in the in the u.s. is that you gotta
make at least $200,000 in salary in the
past two years or have a net worth of a
million dollars or more got it okay and
so today if you don't have that
construction company we want to go raise
capital
we've got reg D right Regulation D which
is an exemption under the JOBS Act
correct reg ass reggae plus and r XE f
a-- so those are the four a rec a plus
in Beck CF a new legal frameworks since
2016 of course okay but no is it a four
main ones and so we what a lot of people
don't understand is when we talk about
these regulations these are exemptions
new securities law so this was part of a
deregulation of the industry right to
make it easier for people to raise
capital without going through the steps
required by legacy securities law real
quick just touch on what were those
steps why was it so hard to leverage
securities law to raise capital before
the regulation exemptions came in so
after the Great Depression securities
law in the u.s. basically draw a red
line in order for in order for a company
to raise money from retail public
non-accredited investors or to raise
money at all you gotta be a register
company meaning a public company meaning
going IPO okay cause of being a public
company just to file the form is a
couple million dollars at least and a
few more million dollars per year it's
just to maintain it and where does that
money go right so so everyone hears that
registering or becoming public company
is very expensive yeah but what are you
paying money for a legal fee of course
the GAAP accounting that is required by
law and just the fleet of accountants
and lawyers to comply with all of that
is extremely expensive internally you
have to have a record-keeping system
just the operational framework to be a
public company is excessively high okay
so either you have to be a public
company or you exempt it by the law from
the registration requirement so you can
raise money from a non accredited
investor if you're one public company
that is expensive and requires a lot of
kind of higher degree difficulty things
to remain public and compliant cetera or
you can leverage an exemption from being
public to raise capital as we're talking
about with reg D reg as a plus graph so
it's not just a retail non-accredited if
you want to raise money from the public
either you have to be fully registered
or you have to fit one of the exemptions
okay
reg d the first exemption says that if
you chose raising from accredited
investors only again millionaires then
that's one exemption but if you've taken
a single non accredited investor you
lose the exemption okay so let's go deep
on reg d for a second if I and you have
the construction company and we're gonna
raise money through reg D we can only
take a credit investors money correct
can we raise as much as we want you can
raise an unlimited amount okay
and how can we mark it to those
individuals so we have to know they're
accredited but can I just go on
television and say hey I'm raising money
do you you know call my cell phone if
you want to put money in or how do I
actually mark it no we're getting to a
deeper level of legal nuances that's why
you're here if you go on TV yes you can
put on a bill boy in the subway you know
watch your trainer go on TV and publicly
announce to the world you're fundraising
but you have to verify that everyone you
are taking in to the route taking money
is truly accredited we have to look at
their tax return or you have to get an
attorney to verify it you know the
verification of accreditation is a is a
pretty complicated threshold if you
don't publicly announce it and you just
go to people that you know and their
friends then you can rely reasonably
rely on people's accreditation
recitation without having to verify so
this is an important nuance if I want to
do billboards television commercials go
on the news kind of publicly solicit
funds from people I don't know yep I
have to verify that they're accredited
yes but if I actually rely on personal
relationships and it's from people that
I know I can simply ask in a kind of
predetermined way
are you accredited and if they tell me
yes that that meets the barrier or that
meets the criteria that I can rely on
their self accreditation yes
so and the threshold is pretty easy and
this is a loose threshold not a legal
threshold you and if you go on live you
google someone's fundraising round and
it doesn't come up you know the person
is technically not publicly fundraising
right you can still do a billboard ad
and somehow doesn't make it on the
internet but nowadays unlikely got it
okay so that's right dee rag ass is what
so reg ass is if you fundraise from
non-us investors outside of the US then
the SEC Securities Exchange Commission
the view that is not our business but
you have to take a few steps to make
sure that your offering is not
accessible by us investors and that you
don't in fact have a u.s. resident
somehow investing in the round so our
construction company we actually we
don't want us investors we want to raise
money from international investors we're
allowed to go do that without having to
comply with us accreditation law correct
if we ensure that US investors won't
invest in the offer but you do have to
comply with the local laws that may tie
to the round okay see how I ask that
question so if we want to raise capital
internationally and let's say that we
have interest in Singapore India and the
UK right we don't have to worry about
the u.s. accreditation criteria as long
as we're ensuring no US investors are
participating but we do have to make
sure that we're compliant in the UK or
India and Singapore correct okay and you
have to take that into account okay
because you won't be in violation of US
securities law but you would be in
violation of the UK India Singapore's
absolutely if you alan singapore
pitching your your offering to
Singaporean resident Singapore laws
would apply okay so in recap reg d
accredited investors in the u.s. pretty
cut-and-dry well understood just to do
it cheap to do and this is a little bit
of the rich get richer because you can
only raise money from rich people
correct right reg s says a lot of the
same stuff but you just won't take money
from US investors you'll take money from
international investors and you'll and
you'll go through the steps to make sure
you as investors don't participate all
right so that's all you know fairly well
understood let's get into the fun stuff
now so we've got reg a plus and we've
got reg C F will start with reg a plus
and I think more people understand that
what exactly is reg a plus and what are
the the things that I can do with that
that maybe I can't do with the other
exemptions so reg CF reg a bliss going
IPO at three ways that you can accept
non-accredited money in the US okay so
IPO reg a + and reg CF correct okay and
I would do
you should look at it is in terms of
complexity and cost
okay so IPO probably a year or more to
prepare for it and the cost is a couple
million dollars all the way to like 1520
million dollars to do just to do an IPO
and then maintenance cost so an IPO
really is time-consuming and expensive
and likely only done by large companies
that are well capitalized etc correct
okay and then everyone anywhere can just
openly buy theirs goes the Apple
Facebook of the world got it
reggae plus is a couple notches below
that in terms of cost and timing as well
okay so law firms now quote about 1
million dollars or so to 2 million to do
the cost of an rec a foul a detractor
legal fee in crypto space the time that
would take for the SEC to approve a
reggae plus you know application can be
six months or eight months or more in
fact today there hasn't been a single
approval by the SEC for a reggae Plus
campaign so a reggae Plus is a little
bit less expensive a little bit shorter
time frame but it's still not this you
know the creation of an LLC which 100
bucks you know couple hundred bucks and
48 hours we're talking six plus months
and still you know hundreds of thousands
if not a million plus dollars correct
and there's a limit on how much you can
raise okay let's talk about that and
that limit is currently at fifty million
dollars and soon will be 75 millions if
you do an IPO you can raise whatever
money that people are willing to to
invest okay so a billion so an IPO I can
raise as much money as I want from
unaccredited investors with a plus I can
only raise up to fifty correct but they
can be unaccredited yep accredited or
unaccredited oil credit okay so me
either is there a limit on the number or
on the cheque size they right yes so
generally no that is the now in reality
the people the type of people would
invest you know millions are generally
oil credited yep so you can go raise I
could raise up to 50 million dollars
from unaccredited investors using reggae
Plus and everyone could put in ten
dollars correct got it how can I find
these people can I go on television and
and you know promote it and billboards
and
and put all over the internet or
absolutely absolutely you can launch you
know your own website you can then you
know do Facebook as to the extent to the
extent that they accept you anything
public promotion advertisement as long
as you disclose it got it so that's
right a plus C F almost nobody knows
about probably the most misunderstood
unknown regulation exemption and so you
guys are focused on correct in for
disclosure the squad Republic's been
doing since summer of 2016 and it's a
big drop-off in terms of everything it
takes about two weeks to launch a
campaign it can be as cheap as three
four thousand dollars but there's a
limit is a pretty low limit no company
can raise more than a million dollars
1.07 to be precise a per year okay so if
we've got our construction company and
we need a couple hundred thousand
dollars or a million dollars to get
started yep we can go takes us a couple
of weeks I'll say you know a month or
less we can spend less than five
thousand dollars we can raise money from
accredited or unaccredited investors
they can write as little as ten dollars
up to whatever size check they want but
we can't raise more than 1.0 seven
million dollars in a 12-month period
correct they actually each invested is a
cap no one can put in more than a
hundred thousand dollars in a reg CF
campaign Oh interesting okay that's the
maximum anyone even a student even if
you are greatly in debt the law deems
that anyone can invest at least twenty
two hundred bucks no question asked okay
above twenty two hundred dollars is a
fraction of your income or net worth so
if you are a teacher making a hundred
thousand dollars a year at a private
school you cannot invest more than ten
thousand dollars in the Rexy F campaign
so you can only view up to ten percent
of your income into a single investment
correct and even you or Tim Draper
cannot invest more than one hundred
thousand dollars per year in in reg CF
opportunity
oh so me as an investor total even if I
like 15 different reg CFS I can only put
$100,000 into reg CF offerings correct
in totality for the year exactly and SCC
in the infinite wisdom saying that hey
if Anthony wants to invest more money in
startups he should go to reg D or wreck
a
but Rex EF is about a small amount of
money lots of people we want to keep it
that way
god no I'm not sure but okay and so why
are you guys using Rex EF is it because
it's more of a democratic way you get
more people and smaller check sizes and
you think that there's advantages there
or explain me why are you so focused on
that specific executive whether it's
about what is traditional finance or
crypto is about access where for crypto
is even that much more important because
you really do need to get these tokens
into the hand of you know developers in
college to start working and building so
if it's gonna cost a project or a
company a million dollars just to do the
legal fouling that's not providing
access that's why it hasn't been
practical at all and IPOs
that's something only for like the
biggest the most major or a type of
companies so there's nothing else in
between it's just either X EF or
accredited only or outside of the US so
we think that is a key component to
bringing open access to capital and to
blockchain in general got it
and so let's walk through what you guys
have built today how big is the company
and then we can talk through you know
how somebody works with you right now we
have two offices the headquarters in New
York with a sigh office in San Francisco
approximately not very many people come
here and say the side office in San
Francisco approximately 40 of us and we
have a pretty balanced team you know we
a lot of people from our team came from
Angeles in fact we deem Angeles to be an
institutional co-founder we have was
strong and technical and business but
one unique differentiator is that there
are I think seven former attorneys to
encrypt enthusiasts working in-house at
Republic to navigate you know that that
murky area at the forefront of FinTech
and securities law got it and so when
somebody comes to work with you can they
sell just regular private illiquid
equity
or do they have to sell tokens we
launched in 2016 to deal with just
equity that is the first 50 companies we
launched which traditional startups
selling convertible notes selling prefer
shares now since 2017 until now given
that most new tokens are deemed by the
SEC to be securities we open up the
framework to allow people to either do a
SAP presale actual token distribution
even air drops and bounty programs as
securities offerings that have to meet
meet one of these exemptions and so the
CF framework at Republic really
accommodates all types of securities got
it and so if I come and I want to
actually raise using a tokenized
security so it's equity in my business
or in that construction company but it's
tokenized can it trade on an exchange
absolutely so today there hasn't been
yet an exchange in the u.s. that has
been approved to do tokenized securities
trading but I have no doubt it will come
by q1 what does the regulation say is
there a 12-month lockup a one-month
lockup three years what what does that
lock look like till you can get to
liquidity
let me give go back to your rec D and
Rex EF distinction and crisis focus on
those two being the most relevant one
for projects in the US if you issue
securities token or equity through a red
D a campaign then for one year they
deemed to be restricted meaning under
very limited circumstances would you be
able to trade and sale publicly okay for
Rexy F immediately anyone can sell a reg
CF securities to accredited investor and
after one year to non-accredited so
there's still that lockup period for one
year got it and let's go deeper on
tokenize securities right everyone's
talking about this and they're saying oh
you know the crypto currencies the
bitcoins of the world right
there's huge potential if it replaces
you know the US dollars of global
reserve currency right we've had Murad
on and just that there's huge potential
there
then there's the icos and utility tokens
which are kind of more access like
tokens right so it gets you onto a
network it gets you some sort of you
know value there but these tokenized
securities there's hundreds of trillions
of dollars of assets in the world and so
if in fact everything becomes tokenized
or digitized what does that world look
like I would say what some deemed to be
somewhat controversial but I think that
amateur tokenized security world will
effectively eradicate poverty around the
world once and fall ok reason why I'm
saying that one point four billion
people have been lifted out of extreme
poverty in the past thirty years it
hasn't been due to government policy it
hasn't been due to philanthropy it's
been entrepreneurships businesses like
ubers and Microsoft creating jobs around
the world those companies today have
been financed predominantly exclusively
by investment funds and by ultra ultra
high-net-worth nine professional
investors so those professional
investors for the past 30 years have
picked a few the data fit their liking
if you open it up for everyone imagine
energy money's basically energy if a mom
stay-at-home mom in China or Argentina
can invest $50 on a tokenized basis in a
project in Canada or the US if you can
imagine everyone participate in early
stage investing in the same way that
they buy products in the same way that
they buy lottery tickets that's that
much more capital will be fuel into
entrepreneurship and the outcome of that
is within a decade or two I really think
that the world will be so prosperous
that we won't see extreme poverty
anymore so highly controversial right
what has to happen now from where we are
today to get to what you just described
and I'll I'll use the pain point of
Republic in the first two years before
crypto as a basis as for my projection
okay so when we launched republic in
2016 allowing everyone quote-unquote to
invest based on that same vision but if
you're sitting in China or Korea or
Argentina and you want to make a $50
investment in a project on Republic
before the tokenized world well wire fee
is alone 50 bucks $35 at the very least
possibly $50 or more that makes it
wholly unrealistic for someone to invest
$50 right after you get it what do you
do how do you transfer if you want to
your interest your investment to your
neighbor you have to go through a very
complex complicated administrative
process those two components are already
being solved if things if the whole
process of fundraising is tokenized
if you invest you know using eath the
transaction fee is so low compared to
traditional finance making it possible
you can also circumvent jurisdictional
cross border limitations that exist with
traditional banking system and then so
where we are today with crypto there's a
major hurdle for adoption the reason why
you don't see more you know stay-at-home
moms participate in crypto that they
don't understand what blocks that means
what foul coin means hack what
blockchain means but if you tokenize a
traditional business real estate
portfolio a construction company they
get it they don't need to know how it's
done all they need to know is that now I
own a piece in this real estate
portfolio and my piece is actually only
$200 write it into a thousand minimum
requirement of yesteryear it's so funny
because the everyday consumer actually
can know that something will be valuable
before professional investors right
because it solves their problem and so
they're on the ground in terms of you
know you talk to these investors a lot
something like oh I saw somebody was
using something and therefore I became
interested in it right or even you know
take Tim for example at Tim Draper why
he start looking at digital assets and
digital currency because his son asked
them for money to buy something on a
video game
like this so that there's you know that
story's told so many times where the
actual investor or the capital allocator
is not the target market for the company
they learn about its solving a pain
point for somebody else and then decide
to invest but if we can empower the
person who has the problem solved for
themselves to actually be able to invest
all of a sudden you start to really
change the dynamics of fundraising
absolutely and in this one other element
which is professional investors only are
only interested in business or projects
that have extreme potential return huge
market size didn't probably wouldn't be
investing in a local restaurant that you
know providing dividends and-and-and
benefits in a robust company but never
year a 10x return on the other hand a
lot of community people would want to do
that and they may not be accredited they
want to invest a hundred dollars in that
restaurant and be able to go to it and
get a discount and call himself an owner
so by opening up by making it easier for
everyone to invest it necessarily funds
a much greater range of businesses and
not just the ones that you know venture
back abou got it let's switch around I
want to play devil's advocate with you
right so the arguments against
tokenization right one is that this
actually isn't that important all it is
is securitization and we've seen this
before the technology is really not that
interesting or that revolutionary what
do you say to that if coming from the
fund asset management background most
people aren't aware that well most
people are aware of credit card
companies taking just a transaction fee
being that middlemen and building you
know billion-dollar industry or trillion
dollar industry fund administration the
same thing
accounting pretty much anything that
requires someone to validate and be the
trusted party in the middle I think that
that trusted party has permeated every
single aspect
to our live and certainly in business I
think I can't think of more than one or
two aspect of businesses that doesn't
that doesn't involve a middleman if you
remove that if you make you're gonna
make it that much cheaper and if you can
help people transact as smaller dollar
amounts you're gonna increase the flow
of capital that combination and increase
pool of liquidity along with less cost
and less inefficiency naturally google
give rise to will be such a boost to the
economy into the war in a way that no
other technology in my opinion has been
able to deliver take god take the
internet as an example what does it do
communication right the ease of
communication of exchange of information
now you're gonna have that taken to the
next level in terms of the ease of asset
transfer and the ease of yeah it in
short one is the one is communication
facilitation the other one is liquidity
facilitation for sure so what do you say
to the people who argue that
tokenization doesn't actually increase
liquidity right it doesn't change what
asset it is and so is it true that it
actually changes the liquidity it
doesn't change the the money supply
right off the bat but net net when you
make it possible for people to
participate in small amount over time
you're gonna have a lot more engagement
it's kind of like voting you can't just
expect one day that you're like hey
everyone can vote now that everyone goes
to the ballot but over the years people
now feel encouraged feel that they have
a voice and then over certain ten years
out and you have a highly engaged
democracy so same thing with money if
you now and enable everyone to
participate both through regulations and
through technology and then by making it
possible and relatable for them you will
have you know improved liquidity at a
great scale over time
okay what about people who say that none
of the infrastructure exists right so
there's no exchange
right now there's none of the things
that we actually need in terms of
empowering this to happen on a global
scale we're six minutes into this new
new day so you know there are a lot of
good people but there's also a lot of
money being deployed in building that
foundation as I mentioned before today
the easin an active securities exchange
in the u.s. they can facilitate crypto
three more months that may very well be
different so you know hopefully an hour
in rather than six minutes in we can
have a you know a lot of the tools
necessary to to justify my optimistic
projection okay
now this isn't a knock against it I
think it's just more of your opinion if
this happens right and all of these
assets do become digital right so
personally my perspective is that a
hundred percent of assets in the world
will become digital every currency stock
bond commodity everything will become
digital in terms of the way that you
interact with it if that happens do we
get away from the siloed financial world
right so the stock exchanges today are
very Western centric if you will do we
actually reach this like one global
financial system that is more inclusive
or do you think that it'll still be
fragmented in terms of you know there's
a certain exchange for real estate
there's another exchange for oil and gas
and there's an exchange for just North
America and that fragmentation persist
or do we actually get to that global
financial system I really hope that we
will get to a point with a global system
in terms of regulations and framework in
terms of market segments I imagine that
it will always be a separate niche
exchange for real estate or commodities
like you know tomatoes and onions and
whatnot and one for you know startups
and maybe one for restaurants one for
real estate so there will be market
segmentations but the hope of a
globalized framework I certainly would
like to see that happen you know within
a decade got it what's your biggest fear
when it comes to tokenization what keeps
you up at night
once a ill-informed piece of law is
enacted it's very difficult to undo it
it takes a lot of time so I would say my
what keeps me up at night would be hasty
decisions or actions by regulators that
maybe New York regulators or the SEC or
FinCEN you know the bitlicense set of
law is one example but I do think with
respect to the SEC they've been very
pragmatic very thoughtful in their
approach so it's encouraging but that
concern applies in all major
jurisdiction may it be Japan which
effectively now has such a high heard of
IC o---- that's not possible to do IC
o---- in Japan because of a reaction to
obviously that's exchange securities
concern over the summer but yeah I would
say regulatory risk not not risk to the
underlying projects but risk of LLL
inform overly restrictive regulations I
think it's completely fair and I would
echo your sentiment and measured and
loose spending the time to learn before
acting whereas maybe we haven't seen
that another jurisdiction so I think
that's completely fair in their view
right now which is the current legal
framework does works if you apply to
crypto it's just that each player gotta
assess for themselves are they complying
and what does ultimate legal risk would
be if they don't but yeah I highly doubt
there will be any drastic change to u.s.
securities law as applied to crypto
anything yes I mean look I've said this
before we wrote up a whole thing around
I actually think the SEC or regulators
in general or going to in some form or
fashion mandate the tokenization or
digitization of assets and it's for one
reason that goes on spoken of in many of
these circles today regulators spent a
bunch of time money and resources to
identify bad actors to identify things
that they did that actually broke the
law or violated regulation and then they
have to build a case to usually take you
know year to years it's very expensive
and then they enforce
they actually go after the people who
did something wrong the promise of
tokenization if it actually happens is
that you are able to KY caml investor
verify myself and my digital wallet
right also either an issue or another
participant in the market you can KY
caml investor verify and then the actual
token in which the security is held can
have all of the information it can have
who issued it when do they issue it what
regulation all this kind of stuff and so
now if you write the code into the law
or I'm sorry the law into the code the
code can actually prevent non-compliant
trades from occurring and so you take
regulators from being reactive and put
them in a proactive position that saves
some time money and resources so to them
this is like a dream come true now it
will take some time for our many
legislators and regulators to fully
understand underlying technical know-how
and and take a view of combining you
know law and technology but yes our
legal system is highly outdated and I
have no doubt that I actually agree
completely that blockchain will benefit
regulations over time you know in to a
great extent yeah look people fear what
they don't understand right but in this
one case it actually is technology that
will make the regulators better at their
job right right okay so before we wrap
up I do a whole bunch of kind of fire
round questions first is what company do
you believe is the most important in
cryptocurrency and blockchain today that
is not your own you can't say Republic
but what's the most important company
out there well one of our lead investor
is finance and I love just how long-term
of an approach today that they've been
at you know adopting I would say by
Nance well why are they important though
right so I agree that they've done a
bunch of stuff right that they've taken
this very particular view but why do you
think they're important to the
ecosystem to have that pool of capital
and deploying it not for near-term for
the wealth generation or near-term
return but instead reinvesting it into
incubating companies that are clearly
not gonna issue token and be a hundred
accident they can sell tomorrow but
there are addressing problems in the
underdeveloped or developing world
I think the by nan slap team divine ends
incubation program I haven't seen anyone
else in the industry with this level of
influence that are playing that long
game that long of a game and because of
that that I think that over time the the
net influence of what they doing today
we're gonna see in years and years to
come
I am uh I'm long cz I think a lot of
people don't understand how kind of
critical he is and the way he thinks so
we'll see what happens there alright
next question if you had a magic wand
you could wave it and change any
regulation or improve any regulation
what would it be I would take away the 1
million dollar limit xcf and make it
much more you know pragmatic and
appealing for for larger projects what
would you put the limit at twenty
million dollars I think would be a
reasonable limit so reg CF would go from
a million 1.07 million to 20 million
dollar limit correct and we submitted a
letter to the chairman of the SEC and
hope that that he can use its discretion
to to lift the cap could they actually
do that you know in my opinion he
certainly has the authority to do so
and so he could actually just decide
this should be a higher limit and we're
gonna go ahead and change it correct got
it maybe we'll tweet at him get him to
uh do that alright what's the one thing
you believe in crypto that you think a
high majority of other people would
disagree with you on
that the fully tokenized world will
probably come sooner than most people
thing I would say in less than 10 years
and that within a decade I still think
that we're gonna get rid of extreme
poverty around the world because we're
gonna see that level of adoption of
cryptic note of crypto assassins do you
think that more people in that 10-year
period will adopt Bitcoin or tokenized
securities they will use Bitcoin to
invest into tokenized assets that is it
may be a tokenized mone and now they're
able to acquire a tiny bit of it or you
know one one billionth of the Ritz
Carlton Dow in in Tribeca and so the
tokenized traditional assets will bring
forth relatability and encourage people
who are now standing on the sidelines
interested but having you know having
dived in to actually take that step to
be engaged got it all right one more
question before and everyone let you ask
me one question so you think of a
question but completely non related to
crypto we're just gonna admit that
aliens exist right so aliens are out
there somewhere we always think of
aliens as comparative to humans right
you in movies and the way that are
depicted in sci-fi it's always some sort
of human-like creature do they have pets
do you think that there's alien animals
and alien human type creatures or do you
think that there's just one homogeneous
creature
my bed would be the did you have pets
Wow pets you know it just feels a human
need for comfort and security you know
to be more and so I imagined that a
highly evolved species probably would
also very have high highly evolved EQ
emotion and if that species has emotion
and it will have things like pet pets
right okay
I think nobody's ever answered it with
an EQ focused answer but I think that
you're probably more right than West
what's the most common answer to that
question the funniest one is that were
the pets right I think the most common
is yes there are pets and everyone's got
kind of a different reason as to as to
why you are one of the most prolific
trip to invest it out there out of the
world of like sto securities tokenized
assets what excites you the most in the
past month that didn't come on your
radar until literally the past 30 days
in terms of a sector a project okay
so imma cheat a little bit probably at
the last 30 days but I think it's
something that is not very well
understood and but it's exciting to me I
don't think we're there yet but people
are building and I've seen a couple of
companies pop up I won't mention who yet
because I don't think that they're
they're public with it I'm really
interested in this idea of on chain cash
flow or on chain debt right and the idea
being that it really doesn't have that
much to do with blockchain it has
everything to do with automation right
and so you know I'm on record as saying
blockchain is simply the foundational
technology that will empower or unlock
the true value of automation right so if
you think about in an automated world
most assets will not comply with that
world because they're not digital so
they're paper-based or they're
electronic based right kind of DCCC
today etc if we can use this technology
to actually create
digital assets native digital assets not
oh this is a representation of a share
in a company but it is the share in the
company right now what you've done is
you've laid the foundation for every
stock bond currency commodity to be
digitized and now automation is
Unleashed so the example that I use is
if you're an employee at a company and
you own a house normally what happens is
you go and you apply for a loan right
and when you apply for that loan the
lender underwrites you and the asset
they say ok what house you're buying how
is the cost how much money you have to
put down what's your ability to pay back
your credit score I'll cuff you then
take up a loan you put some money down
you get paid every two weeks from your
employer that money goes into your bank
account you then take some of that money
and you pay your mortgage payment every
month well my bet is that at some point
in the future your employer is gonna
make two payments they're gonna pay you
your salary
net of that mortgage payment because the
bank or the lender is gonna say all
underwrite you write as the borrower and
I'll underwrite the asset but I'm more
likely to give you the loan and also at
a lower interest rate if I can
underwrite the corporation rather than
the borrower right and so now today that
might be possible to be pretty complex
and inefficient to do and and you know
accountants that companies would hate it
right but if we can actually get into a
truly digital world these micro payments
and the ability to start to automate
this stuff unlocks huge value but also
it changes the way that humans interact
with money because what would that do it
would give you as an individual consumer
cheaper capital yep and we know that
cheaper capital unleashes innovation and
we know the innovation actually changes
inequality right and so that's a really
long threaded thing that it's through
rely on a lot of ifs but I think that
this digitization of assets is the key
to building that future a projects like
Dharma do lead early phase of that
evolution you think so so Dharma for
those they don't know is it's a protocol
which anyone can go on and build debt
like instruments writer or debt like
services on this protocol its based on
watching right I think that they are
absolutely one of the fundamental layers
or and if they don't win somebody will
win in terms of a protocol for debt like
instruments the part that may not be as
popular with the crypto community is I
actually don't know if blockchain is
though is the right technology right we
think a lot about asset management for
our business in the digital age not in
the blockchain age in the digital age
now today blockchain is actually the
best technology right in majority of
cases and so what blockchain is heavily
reliant on in many of those cases is
that we will move to a decentralized
world but if we just moved to a digital
centralized world so not for money for
Bitcoin etc but just you know for dad or
whatever does blockchain have to be the
right technology I don't know yet and I
think that's the work that we're trying
to do to figure that out but if we do
move to a truly decentralized blockchain
world the ability to not only get access
to this and unleash automation but then
do it without central authorities we
could sit here all day and talk about
possibilities right mean it would be
absolutely incredible in terms of the
economic benefit for both individuals
and society that that would unleash so
that's the hope right I mean today the
even truly any example of a truly
decentralized initiative project Network
but hopefully that one day we'll see
some some manifestation of that look
I'll leave you one last thing I actually
wrote about it today Bitcoin in my
opinion is gonna do more to solve the
income inequality gap than anything else
in the world and people that that's an
insane statement from somebody who's you
know just talk in their book right I
went back in 1998 the IMF issued this
paper that describes the impact of
inflation on income inequality and the
things that it talks about is things
like there's insiders and Outsiders they
put me about two camps the insiders are
people who can get inflation adjusted
wage contracts so every year my income
goes up X percent to accommodate for
inflate
and prevent impact of inflation real
asset ownership so when I get paid my
salary I take my money and I put it in
something other than an inflation
currency right things like that Bitcoin
completely removes the dynamic
inflationary rate or the ability for a
central bank to influence that and so if
that if you believe the imf's work that
shows inflation has driven more income
inequality in the last 50 years than
most things if you move to a
disinflationary model in a decentralized
model where there's no influence on a
day to day month month quarter to
quarter basis of inflation interest
rates etc all of a sudden you start to
close that inequality gap right and so
to your point like that's just Bitcoin
over you're talking about even bigger
just all assets in general but I do
truly believe that this is the type of
stuff that you know it's it's the Gandhi
quote right first they ignore you then
they laugh in the fight and then you win
we're probably passed the laughing stage
fights are coming right here see central
bank's a now word this is stupid it's
dangerous it's will see how bad the
fight is right now apparently Jamie
Dimon doesn't give a [ __ ] the the Jamie
Dimon and I are gonna end up friends at
some point mark my words
but but I think that's the stuff that
you know I get excited about and and so
I think we're just getting started here
and the entrepreneurs who are really
kind of understanding the technology
understanding the law are gonna build
things we can't imagine and that's
really where we want to invest right I
think you guys obviously are operating
in justice I think it's exciting I'm
definitely a fellow believer yeah
absolutely all right man thank you so
much for coming is a super fun and we'll
have to do it again as you guys keep
progressing thank you so much for having
me